[Музика]
привіт, хлопці, настав час уроку англійської,
мене звуть непальський Лешон, давайте почнемо
сьогодні, ми поговоримо про
ведення блогів, але перш за все давайте перевіримо
наше домашнє завдання минулого разу, коли я просив вас
позначити значки, тож давайте подивимося на
зображення телефонний дзвінок чат онлайн електронна пошта
мова жестів або текстове повідомлення, тож що
таке мова жестів номер
два, телефонний дзвінок номер три
надіслати електронний лист або електронну пошту номер чотири
текстове повідомлення та номер п'ять чат онлайн
давайте перевіримо, чи є у вас такий самий чи
інший  Браво, у
вас це вийшло чудово, давайте йти далі, і
тому сьогодні ми говорили про ведення блогів
і різницю між форумом і
блогом, давайте почнемо з форуму,
що це таке. Якщо ви подивитеся на
картинку, форум в основному в більшості
випадків організований компанією  не
індивідуально, це створюється користувачами,
теми організовані користувачами, вони
запитують те, що вони хочуть, і це групове
обговорення, багато людей публікують свої
коментарі та обговорюють різні теми,
давайте  подивіться на блог, яка
різниця, тому блог організовано
індивідуально, тому тему створює
автор, а не компанія, в
основному, в більшості випадків це автор,
який вибирає тему, і це
індивідуальний чат, а не груповий чат
людей можуть публікувати або коментувати під
блогом, але є лише одна людина, яка
завантажує інформацію в головну тему,
але це різні речі, що
є загальними речами, і подати заявку для
всіх
на блок і на форум давайте
подивимося
на них обох  використовуються для обміну ідеями
чи думками, деякі фактично ви завантажуєте
інформацію, а ваші читачі коментують
під цим, тому давайте почнемо з форуму,
давайте подивимося приклад, у нас є
приклад на форумі tin tak, і сьогоднішня
тема: ви б хотіли мати вчителів-роботів
робот у вашому класі, і щоб
мати урок з роботом, це
питання для вас, подумайте,
краще як учитель-людина чи гірше, давайте
почитаємо блог, тому це текст для
Ви швидко переглядаєте, і виникає
питання, чи можуть роботи замінити
вчителів-людей у класі, тому фа
тично компанія завантажує інформацію на
орум, і коли читачі за
ишать коментарі під цим, чи хочуть вони, щоб ними ке
ували роботи чи
е дозволяйте мати  подивіться на основний
текст та основну інформацію в
тексті, давайте скажемо ключові слова, тому привіт усім.
Я вибрав онлайн-відео про
вчителя-робота в Японії, тому Японія – це
назва країни, так, це ключове слово, давайте
перейдемо до його імені сая та  це
схоже на вчительку-жінку, тому її
звуть Сайя, а вона вчителька, вона
може викладати різноманітні предмети та свою
програму, щоб показати щастя, смуток, гнів,
страх, здивування та огиду, давайте ще раз
поглянемо на це речення, яка
тут ключова інформація  по-перше, він може
викладати різноманітні предмети, по-друге,
він запрограмований, щоб показувати
різні емоції, як-от щастя,
смуток або гнів або страх, здивування та
відраза, давайте перейдемо до відео,
пояснивши, що ці  типи роботів
можуть бути корисними там, де не вистачає вчителів,
тож основна інформація тут –
нестача вчителів, давайте перейдемо далі,
для мене звучить дуже дивно ключова інформація тут
Я не думаю, що так,
то що, на вашу думку, можуть роботи замінити
вчителів-людей у класі  і
це питання до вас, тож завдання для вас
після прочитання цього уривка, щоб Сайя
могла викладати лише один предмет,
змінюючи його зовнішній вигляд або показуйте
деякі емоції, що, на вашу думку, є
правильною відповіддю,
і ви абсолютно  правильно, це так,
давайте доведемо це за допомогою тексту в тексті, у
нас є речення, воно запрограмовано для
показу різних емоцій, таких як
щастя, смуток, гнів, страх, здивування
та огида, тому подивіться
правильна відповідь,
давайте рухаємося далі, щоб мати інформацію
в  на форумі тепер давайте подивимося
на коментарі, тому перший коментар
написав Люк, і він відповідає на запитання, яке
завантажено, він каже, що ми
відразу розуміємо, що це
позитивний відгук, тому т  йому подобається
це, давайте подивимося на текст і
дізнаємося тут ключову інформацію, подумайте
про це, оскільки сьогодні я дуже
захоплююся технологіями, тому мати вчителя-робота
було б цікавіше для них,
яка ключова інформація тут
цікавіша для  студенти
для підлітків, тому що вони
захоплюються технологіями, вони люблять це,
я й сам люблю технології, я
дуже липкий, тому вчитель-робот
буде запрограмований з великою кількістю інформації,
щоб вони могли відповісти на будь-які
запитання за лічені секунди інформації
ось що ви думаєте, щоб робот був
запрограмований з великою кількістю інформації, і
він міг би відповісти на будь-які
запитання за лічені секунди, іноді
траплялося зі справжніми вчителями, що ми не можемо
відповісти на питання, ми люди,
ми можемо забути, я думаю, що  наявність
вчителя-робота справді
оживить класну кімнату, тому інформація тут,
що робот оживить класну кімнату,
тому клас буде
справді яскравим.  sk, щоб ви відповіли на
це запитання Люк каже, що
вчителі-роботи хотіли б зробити уроки більш
захоплюючими, щоб робити багато помилок, які ви
бачите, мають обмежені знання, що, на вашу
думку, є правильною відповіддю на це запитання
абсолютно правильно правильна відповідь –
зробити уроки більш захоплюючими, давайте перевіримо
з текстом так дивиться, що мати
робота вчителя було б цікавіше
для підлітків, по-перше, а по-друге,
він каже, що робот-вчитель мав
би багато інформації, це,
звичайно, цікаво для учнів, а
вчитель робот-вчитель відповів би
будь-які запитання за лічені секунди, давайте перейдемо
далі, давайте подивимося ще на один коментар,
і цей коментар був сказаний Беллою, тому
давайте прочитаємо текст, який Белла каже, що я не
впевнена в цьому,
тому вона має це,
вчителі-роботи можуть використовувати свою базу даних,
щоб відповісти на запитання коментар коментар  на студентських
роботах та дайте зворотній зв’язок, яка тут є ключовою
інформацією, але вчителі-роботи
не можуть зрозуміти, що
думає чи відчуває учень, чи дати відповідь  емоційна
реакція, яка тут ключова інформація,
яку робот не може зрозуміти, і
учень, що думає, почуття або дати
емоційну відповідь, тому я не думаю, що
вони коли-небудь замінять вчителів-людей,
і плюс я б віддав перевагу вчителю-людині,
щоб ключова інформація тут, що Белла
вважає за краще вчителя-людину, вона не
вірить у роботів, тому такий
коментар негативний, тепер
для вас є ще одне завдання, і у нас є ще одне запитання, тому
Белла вважає, що вчителі-роботи
не зможуть допомогти учням бути
цікавими та піклуватися  про учнів,
що правильно,
скажіть мені, тож давайте подбаємо про учнів,
давайте доведемо це за допомогою тексту, щоб вона сказала,
що вчитель-робот не може зрозуміти,
що учень думає або відчуває, або
дати емоційну відповідь, це підкаже нам,
що Сон кажуть правильний  давайте
трохи потренуємося зі словами, щоб у нас було
чотири слова, і нам потрібно знайти
протилежне для них, тому ми звичайне
назвали марним і нудним, давайте почнемо
з найпростішого безкорисного
навпаки корисно, звичайно, то чи можете ви
навести мені приклад зі словом марно
чи корисно я думаю, що роботи справді
корисні,
вони допоможуть людям давайте йти з
нудним, що протилежно нудному
це легко це цікаво,
тому цікаво поговорити  до робота
О, нудно мені здається цікаво, давайте йти
далі, щоб у нас було нормально і холодно хм, я
збентежена
холодна погода або холодна
емоції давайте почнемо з простого слова
для мене це нормально, тому навпаки
для нормального буде дивно
нормально  добре, ми занадто дивні, тому
розмова з роботом може бути трохи дивною,
тому ви можете сказати, що розмова з роботом
може бути дивною, але в той же час це
цікаво, тому, як ви бачите, залишилося лише
емоційне, тому протилежне для холоду
емоційний Я можу сказати, що я особисто
я дуже емоційний я не холодний
я ділюся емоціями щоразу, і
я використовую мову свого сина, тому
давайте подивимося на ці чотири слова і спробуємо
придумати пару речень, використовуючи
їх напр  mple-роботи дійсно
корисні, і розмова з роботами може бути
дивною, але в той же час дуже
цікавою, але роботи не можуть бути
емоційними, вони більш холодні, а що щодо
ваших речень, ви можете завантажити їх на
свої форуми чи блоги, давайте рухаємося далі, давайте
подивимося  у прикладі блогу це
приклад блоку, ім'я якого
Джеймс, а назва його блоку -
школа-голік, тож, як шопоголік,
людина, яка любить школу шопінгу, голік,
тож, ймовірно, Джеймс любить навчання та
любить школи ходити до школи та проводити
час  у школі проводь час з
друзями та
вчителями, тому він любить школу, давайте
поглянемо на повідомлення, прочитайте його, і я
допоможу вам, привіт усім,
ви не повірите, але всі
вчителі в нашій школі зникають, це добре,
дозвольте мені сказати вам  подробиці, коли я сьогодні прийшов
до школи, ніде не було вчителів,
це було дивно, але я не був
здивований, я подумав, що
вчителі збираються на зустріч з
директором, тому я пішов прямо до своєї
класної кімнати, коли пішов  червоний клас
всі мої однокласники сиділи за
партою і тихо читали, що було так
дивно, що я вирішив приєднатися до них,
коли підійшов до столу, я зрозумів, що
залишив усі свої книги вдома,
шкода, що я просто чекав  наш
учитель прийшов час минув, але ніхто не
прийшов, а учні спокійно
читали свої книжки, як зомбі, мені
це не сподобалося, тому я побіг вниз до
кабінету директора і ви
уявляєте, коли я відкривав двері кабінету,
я прокинувся, слава Богу, що це  був лише
сон чи ні, я повернусь,
так що ти божевільний учений голік Джеймс,
це цікава історія, яка сталася з
Джеймсом
класі учні сиділи
за партами спокійно читали книги,
це дивно,
зазвичай учні не розглядають
книги без вчителя, вони лише
виконують інструкції вчителя,
коли вчитель каже читати книгу
учні, які читають у  Книга без
інструкцій, яку вони не читають, це
дивно,
тому це був сон Джеймса, що
сталося далі, ми поговоримо про це
на наступному уроці, але тепер настав час
граматики, і давайте знову подивимося на
текст, добре,
тому ми  потрібно проаналізувати граматичні
структури та граматичні обороти, давайте
почнемо з першого прикладу, тому, коли я
прийшов до школи, ніде не було вчителів,
тому коли я прийшов до школи,
це був перший розділ, а друга
дія, яка була виконана одночасно,
не було  вчителі це той факт, що
я прийшов до школи без вчителів, тож
давайте подивимося на час стверджуємо, що вибачте, що
це в минулому, і це зараз, якщо Джеймс
розповість нам про щось, що сталося
раніше, зараз чи в минулому в
минулому
так  всі дії відбуватимуться тут
у минулому, давайте знайдемо наступний приклад,
коли я зайшов до класу всі мої
однокласники ми сидимо за партами,
давайте подивимося на ці дві дії,
тож перш за все я зайшов до класу,
це  перша дія, і вони побачили, як мої
однокласники сидять за партами і
читають дві дії, так що процес
сиділи мої студенти, мої однокласники,
мої однокласники сиділи, тому це було
в процесі, і ми називаємо відстань минулого
безперервною, скажімо, що була дія, яка
перервала цей процес, який вони
сиділи  і читання, і в той же час,
коли відбувався процес сидіння і
читання, я прийшов, тому друга дія, коли
я увійшов до класу, перервав цю
дію, я увійшов до класу, я увійшов
до класу, і ми називаємо це минулим
простим, тому дві дії одна в  процес
це минуле безперервно і
дія, яка перериває цю дію
або перериває цю дію,
це минуле просте, чи можемо ми знайти більше
прикладів тут, у тексті, давайте
подивимося так, коли я відкривав двері офісу,
це те саме  коли я відкривав
двері офісу, я розбудив дію,
яка перервала цей процес, я прокинувся,
давайте подивимося ще на одне речення
, коли я  підійшов до столу, я
зрозумів, що я залишив свої книги
вдома, я залишив свої книги, що це,
це минуле ідеальне, тому це
сталося ще раніше, тому це сталося
до того моменту, як ми були в
класі, і якщо ми поглянемо на ці
два  процесів ця дія була раніше,
і в момент, коли я залишив книгу, яка була
до цього,
я залишив книги, якщо ми подивимося на ці
дві дії, я увійшов до класу, і
я знову залишив книги, що було раніше,
перш за все, я залишив  книги, тож
це минуле досконале, а потім я
увійшов до класу це минула
проста сума в термінах теперішнього моменту
ранній момент є минулим простим,
а момент, який був раніше,
є минулим досконалим, тепер давайте трохи
потренуємося, тож тепер давайте  потренуйтеся
писати речення з використанням простого минулого
або тривалого минулого. Пам’ятайте, що
минуле безперервне про процес,
а минуле просте – про дію,
яка перериває цей процес, тому ми маємо
приклад Ste  я миє посуд, а його
мама висушує їх, давайте складемо речення,
але перш ніж проаналізувати ці
дії в процесі, чи
є процес і дія, яка перериває,
хм, вони роблять це одночасно,
тому я думаю, що обидві дії виконуються
в  дія, тому це минуле безперервне,
допоможіть мені з першою частиною
Стів мив посуд, нам потрібно зробити це
в минулому безперервно, тому Стів
мив давайте подивимось Стів
мив посуд, а його мама допомогла мені, його
мама сушила їх, давайте перевіримо його
мама сушила їх,
розривай речення після мене, Стів мив
посуд, а його мама сушила їх,
давайте подивимося на другий приклад, коли вони
йдуть додому, починається дощ, тож у нас є
перша дія, люди, пара ми йдемо
додому,
так що це було  дія вони йшли,
і раптом почався дощ, тому
друга дія була одночасно це
було не так, друга дія
перервала перший процес давайте почнемо з
першої частини вони йдуть додому допоможи мені  вони
йшли вони йшли додому
і друга частина,
оскільки це дія, яка
перервала процес, це
буде минуле, просто допоможіть мені, почався
дощ, скажімо, речення разом
вони йшли додому і почався
дощ,
повторюйте за мною вони були  ідучи додому
і почався дощ, подивіться на
це речення ще раз ця частина дощ
не означає безперервне минуле
це іменник дощ
14:00  вчора він мив машину
так 14 год.  вчора і чоловік
щось робив зі своєю машиною був
точний момент у минулому о 14 год.
вчора, і є лише одна дія
без перерви, тож це, звичайно, процес,
і у нас є слово часу для нас
це слово-тригер, і ми співали о
14:00.  вчора
він мився так о 14:00.  вчора
він мив машину повтор за мною
о 14:00.  вчора він
мив машину, тепер дайте мені більше прикладів,
наприклад, робот мав урок,
це дія так, звичайно,
давайте другу частину, вчитель увійшов до
кімнати, тому у нас є дві дії: робот
мав урок і друга
вчитель увійшов до класної кімнати процес
перервав дію перший знову
минулий безперервний, а другий був
у минулому простому, робот мав
урок, коли вчитель увійшов до
класу,
тепер настав час квесту, тому я збираюся
перевірити, чи ви готові перше речення вони
виправляли робота, коли вчитель
прийшов, чи це правильно так, так, знову дві
дії, вони виправляли робота перша
дія вчитель прийшов друга
дія перша дія, яку ми бачимо, виправляли,
і це допомогло мені так минуле
безперервне, а друга дія
перервана дія минуле просто ще
один приклад о третій вчора у
них був онлайн-урок чи правильно
ні це не в чому проблема
подивіться у нас є тригг  ер словами в ІРІ
вчора згадайте хлопця,
який мив машину о 14:00.
вчора це знак, тому ми маємо
фіксований час у минулому, і фіксований
час показує нам, що був процес
, тому нам потрібно, щоб минуле
безперервне допомогло мені,
давайте перевіримо вчора о третій годині, у
них був онлайн-урок  як
часто у вас є уроки онлайн, давайте
перейдемо до ще одного питання,
коли вона була права в останньому
реченні дзвонив дзвінок, тож схоже,
що тут теж є одночасні дії,
вона була правильно в реченні та
дзвінок дзвонив чи правильно
хм  Я так не думаю, в чому
проблема, що вона писала, вона була в
процесі, і вона була права в останньому
реченні, і раптом Дзвоник
перервав її дію, тому
перервана дія має бути в минулому,
давайте перевіримо, коли вона була права
останнє речення пролунав дзвінок, настав
час для домашнього завдання. Уявіть, що у
вас є вчитель-робот, яким
буде життя в класі, напишіть про це параграф,
а на наступному уроці я збираюся перевіряти вас,
на
жаль,  пролунав дзвінок, і нам потрібно припинити
урок, дуже дякую, до наступного
разу до побачення
[Музика]
ти